please welcome one of my favorite humans
get real union
hello
i'm so happy to be here i did want to
get your take the oscars are this
weekend we've been just talking about
this and your pal regina hall is
co-hosting
and i'm so
interested to hear your take on this are
you gonna watch
what have you talked to her what's the
4-1-1
no i i want her to be able to to to have
this experience and not be pressured by
all of us like you better kill it um i
am beyond proud of her
and um
yeah i just i i'm just proud and i can't
wait to give her a massive hug after she
kills it
i also am so excited i i just i'm i feel
like this is like will smith's year and
i know you co-starred with him in bad
boys too and you know him i mean do you
see this coming dude what are your
thoughts i hope you know
i hope you know when you do the work and
it's so beautiful and it's so well
received and
and you really have shed a different
kind of light on the journey of two of
the greatest athletes of all time and
will
will just such an amazing job so you
hope i mean as an academy voter
i mean i don't want to tip my hand too
much but
um i am i am hopeful that this is will's
year
i totally agree it is time and speaking
of time back in the day
you attended ucla
yeah and i'm a bruin and what were you
studying while you were there
i was a sociology major and the plan was
to you know take the lsats become a a
defense attorney and and that was going
to be my life and you know things change
i got an internship at a modeling agency
um and then the next thing they i know
they were like would you ever want to do
this i'm like no
acting and modeling they're not real
jobs cuts do turns out their real job
and i've been making my living as an
actor
you know for all of these years but i
you know and
until you actually walk in the shoes of
an actor or model or whatever you have
no idea what goes into
you know
why they do what they do or why they're
good at it or not you're talking about
walking in an actor's shoes and i found
this story you were on star trek yes
okay yes one of my first gigs i was i
was on star trek deep space nine i
played warts daughter um yeah it was a
fun random
long experience i didn't know how long
it took to put all that makeup on uh
every day and it didn't dawn on me that
you know when you break for lunch you
still have all of it on and everyone's
like leaving to go to you know lunch and
they're like oh join us over at lucy's
which is this amazing mexican restaurant
across from paramount so i'm literally
cut to i'm walking down melrose
as a klingon i walk into lucy's and
they're like chips and salsa and i'm
like is no one gonna acknowledge that i
am a klingon
if you need a visual because i wanted
one of you as a klingon take a look
there may be more hostile simulation
programs out there
[Laughter]
um
now i love always to talk like girl talk
with you and love it's my favorite
subject um you and dwayne you guys have
been married for seven years
and you have such a beautiful loving
couple goals relationship
and i didn't know this but there is
something about the genius musical icon
known as prince that maybe played a part
in how you and dwayne met is this true
this is true to a degree so prince used
to host these epic parties after award
shows so um i was with my girlfriends i
think it was like going up in this
elevator it was like mia long and
vanessa lachey oh my god and we're going
to this elevator and these two guys get
on and they're like oh my god um you
know dwyane wade is our brother would
you ever want to host a party with him i
was like
yeah whatever let me look up who this
kid is um but that was it and then we
proceeded up to prince's house and had
the time of our lives
and eventually i ended up doing a party
with dwayne and the rest is kind of
history
that just has all the
on it you could ever hope for
[Music]